whatever happens to area the industry
from now on is going to be forced to to
move forward and innovative the Supreme
Court will soon reach its decision on
the much publicized
aerial case a case many believe will
have a profound effect on the way we
watch television as area CEO Chet Cano
gia explains it all started by
rethinking a basic staple of 20th
century analog broadcast technology the
antenna this is actually a micro antenna
it's capable of tuning to any channel
that you've instructed to turn to along
with that we built in a DVR in the cloud
so that you as a consumer can say I
would like to watch ABC you wake up your
antenna by sending it an impulse and it
starts up your DVR so you can pause
rewind save the programming for later if
you want to and it's simple but what
seems simple to Aereo smacked of
copyright infringement to the major
broadcasters and their allies in the
Copyright Act of 1976 Congress mandated
that cable companies must get
broadcasters permission before
retransmitting their programs to the
public broadcasters feel Aereo is
retransmitting copyrighted work to
paying customers and should be subject
to the same retransmission fees cable
and satellite companies currently pay
Aereo is arguing that it is simply a
technology company renting individual
antennas and cloud storage accounts to
individual users and therefore is not
engaged in the public performance of
copyrighted works that are subject to
these fees nobody disputes the fact that
you can have an antenna nobody disputes
you can have an intent on your roof
versus your TV set versus to be in a
matter there's no rule that says how
long the wire should be that connects
your device to your antenna it's
established that consumers can make
recordings in their house Sony and
everybody's got a DVR the cable company
leases you want so what's different
about this the wire is just longer so we
expected some controversy but we also
hoped that that basic simple logic would
sort of sit with people and they would
see the opportunity as opposed to
resorting to the
you know first line of offense which is
lawsuits but unfortunately we were
disappointed after a few circuit court
skirmishes the Supreme Court took up the
case there is no question that this is a
gimmick
Steve F Rose is a television industry
consultant and former lobbyist for the
cable industry the consumer can decide I
want to record you know Game of Thrones
or I want to record NBC or whatever the
cable operator is required to have the
licenses and contracts to send that
material down to the consumer in the
first place including broadcast
television what Aereo is saying is
because of technical terms in the
copyright law this little thumbnail
antenna means that the subscriber has
already received the programming and
then we record it and then we distribute
it to them but we don't have to pay the
broadcaster's because it's free
over-the-air television so we don't have
to pay for it because it's not a
performance at all well the problem with
that logic is of course you didn't pay
for it the first time it's true that the
second time it's not a performance for
profit that you have to pay for but what
about the first time I don't know this
is a loophole so much as just an
indication of how complex copyright law
has become James grimmelman is a
professor of law at the University of
Maryland and co-author of an amicus
brief arguing in favor of Aereo Douglas
Coupland wonderfully called the computer
the every animal machine because it's
capable of acting like anything and
that's the how the internet works it can
act like a cable system it can act like
a storage device its TV its radio its
telephone its telegram its Telegraph its
everything that means that a regulatory
system that treats these different media
differently he's going to throw up its
hands in confusion when it hits the
internet because suddenly your doll
distinction between phone calls and
television collapses april's oral
arguments gave little indication of
which way the justices will rule
if the Supreme Court comes down again
stereo both Kenosha and Aereo's
high-profile backer media mogul Barry
Diller have stated it will likely be the
end of the company win or lose this case
underlines just how antiquated and
unresponsive a regulatory and copyright
framework has become in an increasingly
digital age in the long term the
broadcasters and area are both going the
wedding delivering video over-the-air
indiscriminately like this is a model
that you only use when you don't have
the Internet frankly I think most
broadcasters should be taken off the air
I think their their frequency should be
taken back the government should use it
for Wi-Fi and lots of other stuff that
would be much more beneficial for the
public than what we've got today and if
mr. Canoga and mr. Diller want to argue
the case with us that there's a much
better use for broadcast spectrum I
agree with them and if they want to
argue that the term free TV is a fraud I
agree with them again but playing this
type of game is just a game I'm there to
try to be part of the change and see if
there is something I can do to
contribute for a better experience I
didn't cause this change right the
change has been brewing since the
internet started moving bits around
you